wissen wir jetzt endlich warum manche
menschen homo und andere sexuell sind
jetzt sind die ergebnisse der größten
bevölkerungsstudie zu diesem super
spannenden thema veröffentlicht worden
liegt es an den genen klicks und science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocken nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen um
es gleich am anfang ganz klar zu machen
egal ob sich frau und frau lieben mann
und mann oder aber frau und mann nur die
liebe zählt gleichgeschlechtliche liebe
ist eine völlig normale sache gibt es
überall bei mensch und tier es ist also
vollkommen natürlich verrückt dass man
das heute noch erklären muss aber warum
das ist die wissenschaftliche frage
mithilfe einer großen studie deren
ergebnisse jetzt veröffentlicht wurden
sollte das auch keineswegs in frage
gestellt werden im gegenteil die
fachleute wollen durch die erforschung
der genetischen wurzeln der liebe dazu
beitragen vorurteile gegen homosexuelle
liebe abzubauen denn leider ist es immer
noch so dass nicht heterosexuelle liebe
von einigen menschen und kulturen
abgelehnt wird menschen die sich zum
eigenen geschlecht hingezogen fühlen
werden ausgegrenzt und diskriminiert ein
völlig inakzeptables verhalten das
internationale forschungsteam dass die
erblichen einflüsse auf die
homosexualität genauer untersucht hat
hat sich deswegen etwas ganz besonderes
überlegt die forscher erklären ihre
arbeit nämlich öffentlich somit ist
nicht nur die studie selbst für alle
nachzulesen sondern auch die website
blenden wir hier unten ein
also die website liefert noch einmal
super spannende details zum thema die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wollen so verhindern dass ihnen das wort
im mund umgedreht wird oder aber ihre
erkenntnisse genutzt werden um lesben
oder schwule zu diskriminieren ich finde
das eine super sache und das zeigt
verantwortungsbewusstsein denn so wird
ganz genau klar warum sich die fachleute
diesem thema gewidmet haben welche
ergebnisse bei der analyse
herausgekommen sind und wie diese im
detail zu verstehen sind denn auch wenn
hier bei uns nach viel zu langem ringen
wie ich finde gleichgeschlechtliche
partnerschaften und ehen
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert sind gibt es
immer noch diskussionen beispielsweise
wird hinterfragt warum sich
wissenschaft überhaupt mit solchen
fragestellungen beschäftigt wird dabei
etwa nach einem defekt in den genen
gesucht oder aber nach einem fehler im
verhalten oder in der entwicklung könnte
damit die akzeptanz der
gleichgeschlechtlichen liebe gefährdet
sein oder ist genau das gegenteil der
fall würden lesben und schwule von
anderen mehr akzeptiert und verstanden
werden wenn es eine art ursache für
diesen kleinen unterschied gäbe und an
der aktuellen studie ist noch eine
weitere sache bemerken cent und zwar die
datengrundlage sie basiert tatsächlich
auf den erbgut informationen und angaben
zum sexualverhalten von achtung knapp
einer halben million menschen und das
sind nach angabe der fortune 100 mal
mehr als bisherige untersuchungen
vorweisen konnten
möglich wurde diese wirklich umfassende
studie durch genetische datenbanken
denn hier sind mittlerweile auf
hunderttausende von menschen mit ihrem
erbgut erfasst die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer hatten zudem aber auch noch
die aufgabe die folgende frage zu
beantworten
mit wem hatten sie in der vergangenheit
66 antwortmöglichkeiten standen zur
auswahl von meisten mit dem anderen
geschlecht bis hin zu ausschließlich mit
dem gleichen geschlecht die ergebnisse
der fragebögen wurden dann mit
ergebnissen der so genannten genomweiten
assoziationsstudie verglichen
hierbei suchen die experten und
expertinnen nicht direkt nach genen
sondern nach sogenannten low key gemeint
sind damit bekannte markierung im genom
die mit benachbarten gruppen von
erbanlagen zusammen hängen und jetzt
endlich zu den ergebnissen die studie
zeigt zum einen klar und deutlich dass
der erbliche teil der menschlichen
sexualität extrem komplex ist klar wird
aber auch dass das erbgut zu einem
gewissen teil mitbestimmt zu welchem
geschlecht sich ein mensch hingezogen
fühlt die metall konnten die fachleute
zeigen dass die erbanlagen eines
menschen die sexuelle orientierung zu
etwa einem drittel mitbestimmen doch
auch wenn das auf den ersten blick
bedeutungsschwer erscheint ist es
keineswegs so dass einzelne gene oder
gen abschnitte darüber entscheiden fünf
loki konnten von den fachleuten
aufgespürt werden die statistisch
gesehen mit den berichten der
probandinnen und probanden von
gleichgeschlechtlichen liebes
erlebnissen verknüpfte doch sind es hier
gerade einmal ein prozent der sexuellen
verhaltens unterschiede innerhalb der
gesamten teilnehmer
die damit erklärt werden können andere
gehen beziehungsweise gegen gruppen
hatten noch weniger einfluss ist sind
tatsächlich viele erbanlagen die im
gesamten genom verstreut sind die sehr
unterschiedliche biologische funktionen
haben doch jede einzelne anlage leistet
er einen kleinen beitrag 2 gen
abschnitte beispielsweise haben etwas
mit der regulation von östrogen und
testosteron zu tun das sind
sexualhormone der einfluss dieser
insgesamt fünf identifizierten gen
abschnitte auf die gleichgeschlechtliche
partner wahl sollte aber nicht
überbewertet werden denn er ist laut dem
forschungsteam wirklich gering dazu die
autorin andrea ghana wir haben das
gesamte genom untersucht und fünf
varianten gefunden die etwas damit zu
tun haben ob jemand schon mal mit einer
gleichgeschlechtlichen person sex hatte
diese varianten sind in der bevölkerung
sehr verbreitet aber sie haben nur einen
kleinen effekt gemeinsam erklären sie
weniger als ein prozent der unterschiede
im sexualverhalten eine dieser
genvarianten ist nur bei frauen zu
finden 20 männern und die anderen beiden
bei beiden geschlechtern und so ist ein
entscheidendes ergebnis der untersuchung
dass man aus dem erbgut des menschen
keinesfalls die sexuelle orientierung
herauslesen kann beispielsweise durch
gentests bei der geburt und auch in
naher zukunft wird das laut der vorstand
nicht möglich sein im großen und ganzen
zusammen gefasst sind die ergebnisse der
aktuellen studie also die folgenden die
sexuelle orientierung eines menschen
wird nicht durch ein einzelnes gehen
oder eine genetische region beeinflusst
doch es sind mehrere verschiedene low
key also marker auf verschiedenen
chromosomen die bei schwulen männern
häufiger vorkommen als bei
heterosexuellen männern bei lesbischen
frauen konnten zwei weitere gegen
gruppen identifiziert werden
das sexualverhalten ist extrem komplex
und es konnten keine muster aufgespürt
werden mit denen man das sexualverhalten
einer person sinnvoll vorhersagen oder
identifizieren kann dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher benjamin l ich
denke dass wir einige wichtige dinge
gelernt haben dazu gehört dass es eine
enorme sexuelle vielfalt da draußen in
der welt gibt wir können das in unserer
analyse sehen obwohl diese studie eine
so große basis an probanden aufweist
kann also keine eindeutige antwort auf
die frage gegeben werden welche der
23.000 gene der menschen an
homosexualität beteiligt sein könnten
andere studien bisher konnten bereits
zeigen dass nicht nur vererben sondern
auch umweltfaktoren eine rolle bei der
partnerwahl spielen und homosexualität
in manchen familien häufiger vorkommt
als in anderen mit großer sicherheit
sind es also viele faktoren die eine
gleichgeschlechtliche orientierung
prägend klar ist dass homosexualität
nicht allein durch vererbung
weitergegeben wird manchem
forschungsdienst verfolgung hinweise
darauf dass die sexuelle orientierung
eines mannes in der schwangerschaft der
mutter ihren ursprung hat 2018 wurde
nämlich in einer großen studie zum
wiederholten male gezeigt dass
homosexuelle männer oft einen älteren
bruder haben liegt es vielleicht an
einer immunreaktion der mutter auf ein
protein das für die entwicklung mancher
hirnareale zuständig ist diese
antikörper werden von den müttern schon
in der ersten schwangerschaft gebildet
doch diese wirken dann erst bei der
zweiten prozesse im menschlichen körper
und auch umwelteinflüsse könnten dann
auch noch dazu führen dass sich gene
verändern quasi das gen abschnitte für
homosexualität ein oder ausgeschaltet
werden ganz vereinfacht gesagt
höchstwahrscheinlich ist es eine
mischung aus verschiedenen faktoren
klar ist aber wen man liebt kann niemand
beeinflussen und das ist auch gut so
in der fachwelt kommt die große studie
gut an und wird beispielsweise von dem
humangenetiker markus nöthen als
meilenstein der erforschung biologischer
ursachen homosexuellen verhaltens
bezeichnet der biologe jan kobel aus
heidelberg fast die neuen ergebnisse so
zusammen
diese studie zeigt deutlich dass die
erblichkeit sexuelle orientierung gering
ist und man anhand des erbguts einer
person diesbezüglich nichts ablesen kann
es gibt kein einzelnes gehen was die
sexuelle orientierung bestimmt doch ein
kritikpunkt gibt es das sexuelle
verhalten der teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer um das es hier geht wurde
eher oberflächlich abgefragt und war
nicht spezifisch genug vor allem
hinsichtlich des aspekts das gerade
sexualität so viele ausprägungen hat
homosexualität im tierreich weit
verbreitet
anklicken anschauen und krieg zum
science fiction abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran